[Music]
can we talk about that bobble here for a
second yeah I got it right here
Chris yeah I got it right here no one is
talking about how you've been huffing
paint and your eyes are blue oh I
shouldn't be one color it's my other
favorite thing that I enjoy about this
is how my hair is literally floating on
a cushion of air yes several inches
above my skull it's got its own
personality as it does in real life this
is fantastic by the way thank you I
think those they made it those guys up
there thank you yes I bought it already
they're selling like hotcakes you bought
one yeah they're sweeping the nation
really are they're gonna turn this
economy around let me say something you
and I had our own weeded dinner not too
long ago this little time together
Little John Krasinski time we did yeah
my wife and I had dinner with you and
your lovely wife yes the beautiful Emily
Blunt and I just have to ask you
something how did you guys I'm just
curious she's so stunningly beautiful
and yes you're a very handsome man when
you first met was she intimidating at
all to you yes incredibly intimidating I
was scared out of my mind to even go up
and say hi to her yeah and then on our
first date I decided I'm gonna really
hit the gas and bring her to a gun range
okay yeah yeah I love that a lot of
people are clapping amen
there there clapping and reloading no
like I I think that I was so sure that I
would never end up with her because
she'd be like this is ridiculous I can
have anyone not you that I was like you
know what I'm gonna blow it right away
and then that way you don't feel bad
that's this very smart thing to do so
what did you do you forgot the gun range
and we were experiencing it for the
first time which was pretty great except
I think yelped the first time I was like
it was it was very frightening it was it
was it was a very existential meltdown
to know that those powerful guns are in
your hand right and also the guy next to
us in the stall no joke usually you have
the target out like 50 feet or so I'm
sure this guy had three feet in front of
us had his gun on the little table there
and was going like this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
good good I'm intrigued by this man you
want to meet him place burned to the
ground 30 minutes later uh you you were
at both at a recent Kennedy Center
Honors is that correct yes
we were Meryl Streep was getting honored
as were other people and finally was
asked to present at school do you do you
get to hang with Meryl Streep at all
like this that's an awkward yes this the
Boys and Girls Club I don't know what
that no she's she's incredible and I'm
lucky enough to be friends with her
she's actually the coolest lady in the
world and our relationship started with
when you meet someone that intimidating
the only way to do it I think is to
break the ice with a joke right and we
were doing it's complicated and I the
first time I met her I was answering the
door for her over and over and over
again and the shooting a scene where you
were just opening your door hey all
right and then it was getting a little
scary so I figured I'm gonna make a joke
with Meryl Streep and I said the next
time I open the door I'm gonna be
shirtless just so you know and she went
then you might want to drop and do a
couple more push-ups
and I was like I just got burned by
Merrill Street and now we're like this
yeah that's fantastic you do I hope
you're in shape now yeah I know you
several times on the show in the past
we've talked about your love of
pretending to be a marionette yeah and
I'm curious and you don't know how you
can do it again no no I would never make
you do it again I'm just curious do you
ever what what's happening he's not
gonna jump up and dance around like a
puppet for you let's do it okay we need
we need a profession you always make me
give you a profession let's say you're
promoting a movie right now whales so be
a fisherman how about a marionette
fishermen purvey that doesn't make any
sense here we go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
very nice that's it I felt good about I
hope you feel good